[Music]
drug overdose deaths have skyrocketed in
the United States over the last few
decades for example in 1968 a little
over 5,000 people died from a drug
overdose in the u.s. in 1990 that number
had grown to about 8400 can you guess
how many people died from a drug
overdose in 2016
over 64,000 that's over a hundred and
seventy five deaths from overdose every
day and more than seven every hour
that's the most overdoses in any year in
history and more than 12 times as many
as in 1968 and remember in 1968 was
during the height of the counterculture
and hippie movements when drug use was
actively promoted in some segments of
society to get a sense for how bad the
problem is in some communities consider
the city of Huntington West Virginia
which has a population of less than
50,000 people there was a day in 2016
when Huntington witnessed 26 drug
overdoses in less than four hours
furthermore the increase in drug-related
deaths across the country has actually
been accelerating for example from 2015
to 2016
there was a 22% increase in overdose
deaths which is the largest increase
ever in a single year in the county of
summit Ohio surrounding the city of
Akron
there were 312 overdose deaths in 2016
now that's more than three times as many
as they had had just two years earlier
they actually had to order refrigerated
trailers to store all the bodies because
the morgues didn't have sufficient
capacity in fact drug overdose is now
the single most common cause of death
for people under 50 years old in the US
not car accidents not AIDS not gun
related deaths drug overdoses so what is
going on why have we been experiencing
so many more overdoses today than we
ever have in our history
one word opioids the class of drugs that
includes prescription painkillers like
codeine morphine vicodin and percocet as
well as illegal drugs like heroin
opioids have been around for thousands
of years and they've been the gold
standard medical treatment for pain
since the Civil War
providing genuine relief to millions of
people suffering from severe pain but in
the 1990s something changed
pharmaceutical companies began actively
promoting the use of opioids in the long
term treatment of chronic pain based on
the belief that patients were unlikely
to become addicted and in keeping with
that belief physicians started
prescribing opioids in record numbers
for example in 2012 doctors prescribed
enough opioid prescriptions for every
adult in the United States to have their
own supply for an entire month in 2016
12 states actually had more painkiller
prescriptions than they had people but
what has become painfully clear is that
contrary to the earlier beliefs these
prescription painkillers can be quite
addictive in fact about 25% of people
who are prescribed an opioid drug end up
misusing it and over 2 million Americans
are now estimated to be addicted to
these drugs and like other drug addicts
opioid addicts develop pathologically
strong cravings to obtain and use their
drug and once the body has become
accustomed to the presence of opioids
quitting typically leads to extremely
unpleasant withdraw
all symptoms including severe anxiety
muscle aches diarrhea and depression the
unde result is that once you're hooked
it's extremely tough to quit and as a
result many users turn to illegal
opioids like heroin once their
prescription runs out in fact about 80%
of heroin users first misused a
prescription painkiller many addicts
also resort to crime even stealing from
family and friends as they become more
and more desperate to feed their habit
and many also end up losing not only
their jobs but also their friends and
their families and in far too many cases
they also end up losing their lives
furthermore the distribution and sale of
prescription painkillers is extremely
lucrative and some corrupt doctors
pharmacists and distributors have made a
lot of money by supplying these drugs to
people without legitimate medical needs
for example two drug stores around
Kermit West Virginia sold over three
million doses of opioid painkillers in a
single year and do you know how many
people live in Kermit about four hundred
another significant factor that has
contributed to the current epidemic of
opioid overdoses is the availability of
more powerful synthetic opioids
particularly fentanyl fentanyl was
originally developed as an intravenous
anesthetic for use in surgery but in the
1990s it began to be used for pain
relief first as a slow-release skin
patch then as a lollipop a dissolving
tablet and an oral spray it's very
useful in the treatment of pain because
it has a relatively high therapeutic
index meaning that the dose required for
pain relief is much smaller than the
dose that would be lethal and as a
result there's a fairly wide margin of
safety when it's prescribed
by a physician and the dosage is
carefully controlled but fentanyl is
extremely potent in fact it's about 50
times more potent than heroin so a very
small dose can have a very strong effect
and that makes it extremely dangerous
when it's used recreationally and
without careful controls because a dose
as small as three milligrams can kill an
average-sized adult male that's less
than the weight of a single grain of
sand and believe it or not there are now
fentanyl analogues that are even more
powerful actually a lot more powerful
one of the worst is a synthetic opioid
called car fentanyl remember I mentioned
that fentanyl is about 50 times more
potent than heroin well car fentanyl is
about 5,000 times more potent than
heroin it's actually used as an elephant
tranquilizer it's so powerful that it's
considered by many to be a chemical
weapon in fact it's suspected to have
led to the death of a hundred and
seventy people in the 2002 Moscow
theater hostage crisis in which a group
of Chechen nationalists held hundreds of
people hostage and demanded that Russian
forces be withdrawn from Chechnya well
after a four-day standoff Russian
Special Forces pumped a gas that may
have included car fentanyl into the
theater in an effort to knock everyone
out
unfortunately the gas was so powerful
that about a hundred and thirty of the
hostages died before they could be
treated
now fentanyl car fentanyl and other
fentanyl analogues are now widely
available on the street they're often
cut into other drugs like heroin or
cocaine as a way to increase profit
margin and that's because they're fairly
cheap and easy to get in fact these
drugs weren't even regulated in China
until March of 2017 and The Associated
Press identify
twelve Chinese businesses that would
willingly export car fentanyl for about
$1,250 per pound to anyone on the
Internet and some people took advantage
of that opportunity for example in June
of 2016 the Royal Canadian Mounted
Police seized a 1 kilogram shipment of
car fentanyl that had been shipped from
China to Canada in a box labeled printer
accessories well that's enough car
fentanyl for 50 million
lethal doses in other words that single
one kilogram shipment was enough to kill
the entire population of Canada
well as you can imagine these extremely
powerful synthetic opioids have
contributed substantially to the death
toll from drug overdose for example
within six months of car fentanyl's
introduction to the streets of Akron
Ohio about a hundred and forty overdose
deaths tested positive for the drug the
bottom line is that the opioid crisis is
very real and very deadly and if we want
to stop it or at least reduce the damage
we need to understand how these drugs
work at a biological and neural level
how do they produce the effects that
they produce why are they so addictive
and is there anything that we can do to
counteract their effects first of all
let's talk about what opioids are and
how they produce their effects
well opioids get their name because they
are related to opium the dried form of
the milky latex that is secreted by an
opium poppies seedpod when it's
scratched
opium contains both morphine and codeine
these are so-called opiate drugs which
just means that their natural
ingredients of opium itself the more
general term opioid refers to drugs that
have biological effects similar to the
natural opiates
whether they're found in opium or not
for example heroin is an opioid drug
that's very similar to morphine but
about three times more potent
although heroin isn't found in opium
itself it's biological effects are very
similar to those of the natural opiates
and so it would be classified as an
opioid drug
likewise prescription painkillers like
vicodin and percocet contain opioid
drugs that are derived from chemicals in
opium but that aren't found in opium
themselves now some of the most powerful
opioid drugs like fentanyl and car
fentanyl are completely artificial and
man-made and they aren't even derived
from opium or its contents but because
their biological effects are similar to
the biological effects of the opiates
they are also classified as opioids so
what are those biological effects well
first and foremost all opioid drugs
interact with the same receptor
molecules in the brain and body
in fact these molecules are called
opioid receptors precisely because they
interact with opioid drugs receptors are
kind of like the ignition in your car
and opioid drugs are kind of like your
car key your car key fits the ignition
of your car but it doesn't fit your
front door or the ignition of your
neighbor's car and when you put your key
in the ignition of your car it causes a
chain reaction of events that can start
the car
likewise opioid drugs fit into opioid
receptors but they don't fit any of the
countless other receptors throughout
your body and when an opioid drug
connects with an opioid receptor it
triggers a chain reaction of cellular
events that ultimately produce the
effects associated with opioid drugs for
example the deadly effects of opioid
drugs are caused by their interaction
with OPI
receptors in the brain stem that affect
breathing in particular activation of
these receptors can significantly
suppress the breathing reflex and an
opioid overdose can suppress breathing
so much that the user suffocates and
dies from a lack of oxygen the pain
relieving properties of opioids depend
on a different set of opioid receptors
on cells in the bodies pain pathways
when these receptors are activated they
block pain signals from reaching the
brain thereby providing significant pain
relief
you also have opioid receptors in your
digestive system and activation of those
receptors can lead to constipation and
nausea
both of which are commonly associated
with the use of opioid drugs finally
there are a lot of opioid receptors in
the brain's reward circuit and when
those receptors are activated the user
experiences a feeling of peaceful
euphoria and that's why opioid drugs
like heroin produce what users describe
as a warm euphoric high the activation
of these opioid receptors in the reward
circuit also leads to the release of
unusually large bursts of the
neurotransmitter dopamine and those
bursts of dopamine are what make opioids
and all other drugs of abuse so
addictive to understand why we need to
understand how the brain interprets the
release of dopamine in the reward
circuit and there are two important
parts of the puzzle that together help
to explain the neural mechanisms of
addiction
the first is dopamine's role in craving
and the second is dopamine's role in
reward prediction first consider craving
for a long time scientists thought that
the release of dopamine reflected
pleasure or liking but a number of
studies now suggest that dopamine
release is really more about wanting and
not normal run-of-the-mill 1/2
but intense craving for example mice
that have been genetically engineered to
release more dopamine than normal seem
to crave food in a way that normal mice
don't for one thing they will run much
faster and farther to get it compared
with normal mice conversely mice that
have been engineered not to produce
dopamine exhibit the Optive opposite
symptoms they don't show any signs of
wanting food at all in fact they won't
bother to walk across their cage to eat
even if they're starving to death on the
other hand these genetic alterations in
dopamine levels don't seem to influence
how much the mice like food for example
mice typically exhibit characteristic
facial expressions and mouth movements
when they eat something that they
particularly like but mice that produce
more dopamine than normal don't produce
any more of these characteristic
expressions when they eat than other
mice do and mice that produce less
dopamine don't produce fewer such
expressions the bottom line is that a
burst of dopamine in the reward circuit
is associated with wanting or craving
more than liking and we're not talking
about thoughtful planned wanting like
the long-term goal of wanting to be an
engineer or a lawyer we're talking about
short-term cravings like wanting to eat
some chocolate even though you're going
to eat dinner soon or wanting to watch
the next episode of a TV show that
you're binging even though it's late and
you need to get up early so point 1 is
that the release of dopamine in the
reward circuit is associated with
craving the other important point to
keep in mind is that the release of
dopamine signals what's sometimes called
a reward prediction error now some of
the most important studies on this topic
were conducted by dr. Wolfram Schultz
who was at the university of freiburg at
the time dr. Shultz trained
monkeys to perform a task in which they
received fruit juice as a reward at
relatively predictable times while they
were doing this task he recorded from
neurons in the reward circuit of their
brains and he found that these neurons
fired and released dopamine when a
reward occurred but only if that reward
was unexpected if the monkeys got some
juice when they weren't expecting it
then these dopamine neurons fired and
produced a burst of dopamine but if the
monkeys were expecting the juice then
the neurons didn't release dopamine now
Shultz interpreted these results to mean
that the release of dopamine in the
reward circuit signals a reward
prediction error in other words dopamine
is released not when you get a reward
but rather when you get more reward than
you were expecting to get in other words
when your prediction about the amount of
reward was wrong
furthermore a long line of research in
psychology had previously shown that
errors in reward prediction trigger new
learning and that makes a lot of sense
after all if your predictions are
correct there's no real need for new
learning it's when your predictions are
wrong that you really need to learn
because that's when it's clear that your
model of the world isn't quite right and
it needs to be updated and what do you
learn well you learn associations
between the current situation and the
arrival of a reward so then the next
time you're in a similar situation
you'll be better able to predict what's
going to happen dr. Schultz also found
that over time the dopamine neurons
started firing in response to the
environmental cues that preceded the
reward in one of his experiments a light
flashed a second or two before the juice
arrived and he found that once the
monkeys had learned that the juice was
associated with the light then their
dopamine neurons would fire in response
to the light rather than the juice
okay so dopamine release is associated
with craving and it also signals reward
prediction error and it triggers
learning associations between the
current situation and the future
appearance of a reward but what does any
of this have to do with opioids and with
opioid addiction well remember when an
opioid drug binds to opioid receptors in
the reward circuit it artificially
triggers a big burst of dopamine but the
brain doesn't know that the dopamine
burst was triggered artificially by a
drug so it treats it as if it had been
triggered by an unexpected natural
reward like food or praise and then the
brain does the two things it always does
in response to a dopamine burst first it
learns associations between the current
situation and the likelihood of future
reward and in the case of a drug user
that means learning strong associations
between the environmental cues
associated with drug taking and drug
taking itself for example the people the
user is with get associated with drug
taking the room where the user takes the
drug gets associated with drug taking
the needle or pill bottle or other
paraphernalia that are present gets
strongly associated with drug taking and
so on any and all environmental features
that are associated with drug use get
burned into the users memory and the
second thing that the burst of dopamine
does is to trigger craving and because
opioids and other drugs of abuse produce
abnormally large bursts of dopamine the
cravings are also abnormally strong and
remember over time the dopamine neurons
start firing in response to the cues
that predict that the reward is coming
not just in response to the reward
itself for the drug user that means that
all the cues that are now strongly
associated with drug taking all
trigger craving themselves just seeing
the people with whom you've taken drugs
in the past triggers a dopamine burst
and a strong craving to take the drugs
again
likewise walking by a location where you
once used the drug also triggers craving
so does seeing drug paraphernalia or
encountering any of the other hundreds
of other cues in the environment that
have become strongly associated with
drug taking with repeated drug use those
associations get stronger and stronger
and the cravings become so powerful that
they're virtually impossible to ignore
and pretty soon a full-blown addiction
is born so in a very real sense opioids
and other drugs of abuse fool the brain
into behaving as if there's no more
rewarding behavior in the world than
taking that drug and over time that's
exactly how addicts act they become
obsessed with obtaining and taking the
drug and everything else in their lives
becomes a lower priority and that's when
you see the tragic downward spiral of
neglected responsibilities broken
relationships and even criminal behavior
that's associated with drug addiction
finally let's turn to perhaps the most
important question of all is there
anything we can do to help these people
and ultimately stem the tide of the
opioid epidemic well yes and no there
are some very effective treatment
options and there's some promising
research directions but we still have a
long way to go if we want to really
address the crisis let's begin by
talking about treatment options and when
we talk about treatment it's important
to distinguish between treatment for an
overdose and treatment for the addiction
now in the case of overdoses a
medication named naloxone can be used to
quickly and effectively counteract the
effects of opioid
drugs naloxone is what's known as an
opioid receptor antagonist what that
means is that it binds to opioid
receptors just like opioid drugs do but
it doesn't turn the receptor on it just
blocks the receptor and it prevents
opioid drugs from turning it on if you
think of our key and ignition analogy
naloxone is like a fake key that you can
slide into your car's ignition but that
you can't turn furthermore while it's in
the ignition it prevents you from
putting the real car key in and so
there's no way to start the car while
the fake key is in the ignition
likewise naloxone binds to opioid
receptors but it doesn't turn them on it
also prevents opioid drugs from turning
those receptors on and it replaces drug
molecules that were previously bound to
those receptors in particular it
prevents the drugs from activating
receptors in the brain stem that
suppress breathing and that could lead
to asphyxiation and to death in fact
administering an appropriate dose of
naloxone to a victim of an opioid
overdose can often reverse the effects
of the drug in just a minute or two and
save their life now that's obviously
great news but there are at least three
significant problems first and foremost
not everyone who overdoses on an opioid
drug gets treated with naloxone in time
if no one is around or if those who are
around don't call for medical help right
away
then it may be too late in response to
this concern first responders like
paramedics and policemen now often carry
naloxone with them at all times so that
if they encounter someone who has
overdosed on an opioid they can treat
them right away opioid users themselves
as well as their friends and family can
often get a naloxone prescription to
keep in case of emergency
a second problem
is that the new synthetic opioid drugs
like fentanyl and fentanyl analogs are
so potent that the usual doses of
naloxone may not be strong enough to
counteract the effects of the drug and
in such cases it may be necessary to
repeatedly administer multiple doses of
naloxone every couple of minutes until
the victim finally responds of course
that's a problem if you don't have
enough in a lock zone or if the person
administering that naloxone doesn't
recognize the need for multiple doses
furthermore the effects of naloxone only
lasts about 30 to 90 minutes while the
opioid drug may stay in the system
significantly longer so an overdose
victim who initially responds to
naloxone and recovers could still
overdose an hour or two later even if
they don't take any more of the drug
it's therefore critical for any overdose
victim to get immediate professional
care and to be closely monitored for an
extended period of time but the third
and perhaps most serious problem is that
naloxone only treats the overdose not
the underlying addiction as a result
it's quite likely that an overdose
victim who is saved by naloxone will
overdose again in the not-too-distant
future in fact a study that tracked
emergency room patients who had been
successfully treated with Ana locks on
for an opioid overdose found that about
10% of them had died within a year from
another opioid overdose and 5% of them
had died within a month
clearly naloxone alone is not the entire
solution we need to find ways to help
people escape the addiction itself but
how well the most common approach is to
replace the use of illegal opioids with
the controlled administration of safer
legal opioids that's the idea behind
what's called methadone maintenance
therapy now methadone is another
opioid drug and so administering it to
an opioid addict will significantly
reduce their cravings and it will also
prevent them from experiencing the
extremely unpleasant withdrawal symptoms
like anxiety and muscle aches that
quitting cold turkey would produce when
administered by a professional in a
clinic methadone is much safer than a
street opioid like heroin for one thing
the dosage is controlled and so there's
virtually no chance of an overdose for
another the methadone from the clinic is
pure while street drugs are often
contaminated by other substances
including potentially very dangerous
synthetic opioids like fentanyl or car
fentanyl methadone also doesn't produce
the strong euphoric high associated with
other opioids like heroin and fentanyl
and perhaps for that reason once an
addict has switched to methadone they
might they may find it easier to slowly
reduce their dose and ultimately kick
the habit entirely but other opioid
addicts stay on methadone maintenance
therapy for years on end and although
they're still addicted to an opioid
many of these addicts can return to a
relatively normal life they can hold
down a job and develop relatively normal
relationships
so although methadone maintenance may
not be as desirable as complete
abstinence it's a lot better than living
from hit to hit on the street okay where
do we go from here in our fight against
this opioid crisis well in May of 2017
the director of the National Institutes
of Health and the director of the
National Institute on Drug Abuse
suggested three major research
directions that scientists could pursue
in order to address the issue the first
idea is to try to develop new overdose
reversal interventions that are better
than the current approaches for example
scientists could develop
new drugs that are strong enough and
long-lasting enough to counteract the
effects of the powerful synthetic
opioids more effectively than naloxone
can scientists could also develop
technologies that detect overdose and
that automatically intervene by
signaling for help or by administering
an opioid antagonist like naloxone even
if no one else is around the second idea
is to develop new approaches to treating
opioid addiction itself as we discussed
addiction leads to neural changes that
lead to craving and compulsive drug use
well if those neural changes could be
counteracted in some way then we could
potentially treat the disease rather
than just the symptom one promising
possibility is to develop vaccines that
cause the body's own immune system to
attack opioid drugs and prevent them
from entering the brain a third idea is
to improve the way we treat pain it's
important to remember that opioid drugs
still play a crucial role in relieving
the suffering of countless patients with
chronic pain but unfortunately when the
current drugs are used long-term they
can be habit-forming
what's needed are new ways to treat
chronic pain that are safe and effective
but that are not addictive and there are
a few promising candidates on the
horizon for example drugs called biased
agonists seem to be able to bind to
opioid receptors in the pain pathways
without producing the undesirable
effects on breathing and the reward
circuit non-opioid approaches like
medical marijuana and brain stimulation
have also shown some promise
so although the current crisis is very
serious there's light on the horizon and
reason to be cautiously optimistic about
the future well thanks for joining me
for this discussion of the present-day
opioid crisis in America if you'd like
to learn more I developed an entire 12
lecture course called the addictive
brain that I
you'll try out thanks for listening
[Music]
the opioid epidemic America's deadliest
plus watch thousands of lectures like
this one from world-class professors and
experts on topics such as science
history math health music and more visit
the great courses plus calm to learn
more
[Music]
[Music]